This is the brief on Charlie
Kirk's assassination, free
speech and the implusion
trigger.
OK, So what we're looking at
here is this really intense
essay.
It analyzes the fictional 2025
assassination of Charlie Kirk,
you know, the political guy.
And it uses this wild analogy, a
nuclear bombs implosion trigger,
to argue that when you try and
force hostile speech
underground, it doesn't actually
go away.
It just compresses all that
anger until, boom, it explodes
into real violence.
All right, so three big things
to pull from this.
First off, there's the event in
the essay itself, Kirk getting
killed in September 2025.
Right away, it's labeled as
Sarajevo moment.
You know, like that one shot
that triggers a massive
escalation and the fallout
totally global.
Trump promising vengeance, his
VPJD, Vance calling Kirk a
martyr, Far right protests
erupting like everywhere,
London, Rome, you name it.
OK, second, why did it explode
like that?
Well, the essay digs into this
implosion trigger theory.
It's basically saying, look,
when institutions punish
dissent, you know, cancel
culture, people losing jobs,
getting expelled, that
hostility, it doesn't just
vanish, it gets all
concentrated, like social
pressure building up, turning
ugly words into actual real
world violence.
It kind of metastasizes.
And finally, how do we prevent
this kind of thing?
The essay talks about this
paradox.
Stern mercy.
Sounds weird, right?
But it means protecting the
speaker's right to talk even if
you hate what they're saying,
while also strongly challenging
the speech itself.
It means institutions got to
tolerate tough disagreements and
really defend free speech using
the Brandenburg Doctrine
standard, which basically says
speech is only punishable if
it's directly meant to incite
violence right now.
So the bottom line, if we want
to avoid political implosion,
it's got to be about resilience
and restraint, not jumping
straight to vengeance.
Welcome to the debate.
Our focus today is on the
analysis following the 2025
assassination of Charlie Kirk,
an event described in the source
material as a well, a Sarajevo
moment.
The global political fracture
that came after really exposed
an unnerving fragility in, you
know, modern societal discourse.
And the discussion really
centers on the source's primary
framework, this chilling nuclear
analogy.
It calls the implosion trigger.
This theory that conventional
discourse, words, dissent, even
outrage can act like those
explosive lenses compressing a
nuclear core, pushing a brittle
society past a point of no
return towards large scale
political violence.
Exactly, the material argues the
structural failure causing this
collapse lies in how we manage
speech.
So our central question for
debate today is this does the
primary danger of societal
implosion arise mainly from the
institutional suppression of
difficult or offensive speech,
which the argument goes builds
up concentrated hostility?
Or is the more potent immediate
threat the sophisticated high
speed amplification and
strategic arrangement of
inflammatory words that
actually, you know, triggers the
detonation?
Right, 2 related but distinct
failure points.
Yes, and I'll be arguing that
the long term structural
mechanism of institutional
suppression and punishment is
the chief factor.
It creates a society brittle
enough to implode.
Suppression is the compression
mechanism, essentially.
OK.
And I'll maintain that while
yes, institutional failures
create underlying fragility, the
sheer speed and calculated
precision of modern digital
amplification constitute the
immediate and most potent
danger, acting as the final
detonation charge that
transforms that concentrated
pressure into catastrophic
implosion.
OK.
Well, let me start then.
The source material provides, I
think, a pretty clear diagnosis
of structural failure, detailing
what it calls the ladder of
escalation.
It emphasizes that when
difficult or or hostile speech
is choked, you know, when people
are deplatformed, fired, shamed
into silence, those sentiments,
they don't just vanish.
Instead, the text says, they
metastasize and find darker
channels.
Mm Hmm.
So I assert that institutional
punishment of dissent, the loss
of jobs, academic expulsions,
social shaming campaigns, what
we generally might call
institutional cancel culture,
these are the critical early
steps on that ladder.
This suppression paradoxically
doesn't prevent violence.
It actually concentrates the
hostile material, forcing it
inward, creating the high
pressure pit needed for
criticality.
The source even calls every
punitive cancellation of Mini
Versailles breeding precisely
the kind of deep, concentrated
resentment that leads to the
next major political conflict.
OK, I see why you think that,
but I would frame the
relationship between the
structure and the trigger well
differently.
I agree that institutional
failures build the core of
hostility, definitely.
But a bomb needs more than just
compressed material, right?
It requires A precise engineered
detonation.
The material describes the true
drivers of criticality not
really as the gradual buildup,
but as the precision and the
timing of the final charge.
The text points explicitly to
the high speed strategic
elements.
Outrage influencers are
explosive lenses.
Retweet storms are detonation
wires.
Media amplification is
compression.
Now, if society is already near
critical mass due to those prior
failings you mentioned, the most
acute threat becomes the
orchestrated global noise that
instantly forces the symmetry
and timing required for
detonation.
The danger, I argue, is the
calculated, strategic use of
words by political actors in a
moment of crisis, not just the
institutional failings that
might have preceded it.
But that immediate detonation
you describe, it can only be
effective if the social
structure is already too brittle
to absorb the shock.
I mean, if institutional
resilience were high, if
citizens were, let's say, A
accustomed to hearing ugly words
without immediately demanding
punitive consequences, the
amplification wouldn't find
purchase, would it?
The source's key paradox here is
foundational words must be
tolerated because they are
dangerous.
Suppression is the structural
flaw that ensures the resulting
hostile energy is organized into
a symmetrical concentrated
pressure field, basically making
it ready for the smallest
trigger.
I come at it from a different
way though.
The immediacy of the detonation
as described in the source.
It forces us to prioritize the
active trigger over the, let's
say, passive structure.
We saw the true danger in the
week following Kirk's
assassination.
This wasn't some slow pressure
release.
It was instantaneous political
warfare.
You had Trump blaming the
radical left, JD Vance endorsing
doxing campaigns against
journalists, Elon Musk calling
Democrats the party of murder.
I mean, this was rapid, global
and highly orchestrated
political manipulation.
Right, the reaction was
immediate.
Exactly.
So if the danger is truly an
implosion, a process needing
exact symmetry and timing, then
the strategic use of high speed
media to organize and focus
political hatred instantly is
the primary mechanism of
failure.
And I think that far surpasses
the gradual pressure buildup
from suppression in terms of
immediate danger.
OK, let's ground this in the key
metaphor.
The source uses the explosive
lens.
You focus on digital outrage
patterns as the lens, but I
argue the institutional punitive
action is the original lens.
The source argues that by
denying hostile sentiment and
outlet, the institution
compresses the core, that
denial, the cancellation, the
punishment.
That's the mechanism that shapes
the energy internally, making it
symmetrical and concentrated for
implosion.
It sets the condition.
I'm sorry, but I just don't buy
the institutional silence is the
active lens.
That confusion between structure
and action seems key here.
Institutional suppression
creates the fuel and
concentrates it, yes, but the
source defines the metaphorical
explosive lenses specifically
as, and I quote, social media
outrage patterns that compress
discourse into violence.
That implies the actual act of
compression.
The engineering of the symmetry
comes from the digital
organization of outrage, forcing
the mass to reach criticality.
But isn't that digital
organization only possible
because the underlying material
is already concentrated?
Well, think of the real world
analog the explosion of
conspiracy theories.
The material suggests that
institutions trying to scrub
forums or de platform users on,
say, peripheral platforms only
push those groups to more
obscure, focused and pressurized
channels.
OK, that is compression, I grant
you, but it's the subsequent
precise targeting of these
groups by outrage influencers
delivering focused political
charges at high speed.
The retweet storms, the
immediate coordinated targeting
that achieves the critical
symmetry needed for widespread
real world action.
So we have to prioritize the
precision of the detonation, I
think, over the existing
pressure.
But that digital warmization
only achieves fatal symmetry
because years of institutional
suppression have fundamentally
weaken the social containment
field, what the source calls
cultural toughness.
The outrage hit so hard because
the public arguably already
lacks the resilience to hear
ugly words without immediately
demanding political action or,
you know, punitive sanctions.
OK.
And let's look at the
institutional response after the
assassination.
This touches directly on your
point of amplification, but I
think it proves my point about
underlying fragility.
The material documents how the
political fracture accelerated
when institutions responded well
performatively.
Flags that have Stafford Kirk
the Pope praying, Fox News
announcing A tribute, Comedy
Central pulling a mocking South
Park episode.
Exactly.
That week proves institutions
weren't passive failures.
They became powerful amplifiers.
Now did these establishment
reactions accelerate the
fracture or did they provide
necessary containment?
I argue the coordinated
amplification and frankly,
canonization of Kirk.
That sudden unified global noise
was a calculated political move
that further drove society past
criticality.
Institutions were supposed to
absorb the shock and model
resilience.
Instead, they jumped right into
the high speed political
theater.
I acknowledge their immediate
failure to moderate absolutely,
but I stress that this
amplification was only so
devastating because of the
pre-existing fragility caused by
those prior suppressive
failures, The source argues the
real goal should have been
institutional resilience, the
ability of citizens to hear ugly
words without collapsing.
And this resilience, the
argument goes, was destroyed by
years of institutional
overreaction to mere
transgression, paving the way
for the later destructive
amplification to take hold.
If the Republic wasn't brittle,
if the pit wasn't already
concentrated, the digital noise
might have just been noise, not
a detonator.
So just to be clear, you were
arguing that if a few
universities hadn't fired or
punished figures years before
for, say, offensive speech, then
the calculated global political
outrage, the orchestrated
efforts by major political
figures media outlets in the
week following the assassination
would have simply dissipated
harmlessly?
That that seems to put too much
weight on the initial
containment failure, and maybe
too little on the massive
organized power of calculated
political outrage operating at
today's speeds.
The threat feels like it has
evolved past just structural
weakness.
It feels tactical now.
I'm not convinced by that line
of reasoning, primarily because
the sources only stated solution
hinges entirely on restoring
that structural resilience.
The only solution actually
provided is this paradoxical
concept of stern mercy to
protect the speaker's civic
right while actively socially
rebuking the speech's content.
Stern mercy, yes.
Embodied by that gospel phrase,
Neither do I condemn you.
Go and sin no more.
This framework requires
defending the civic square,
maintaining legal restraint,
something like the Brandenburg
Doctrine, which only punishes
speech, inciting imminent
lawless action while allowing
robust social correction of the
content.
This balance, the source
implies, is mandatory to prevent
the pressure pit from forming in
the first place by legally
dispersing the hostile energy
while socially managing the
content.
That's, well, that's a
compelling argument because if
it does define the only path out
of that binary trap of what is
the source?
Call it indulgence or vengeance,
which it notes secular
liberalism tends to collapse
into.
OK.
However, have you considered the
practicality, I mean the
practicality of implementing
such a delicate, highly nuanced
ideal, stern mercy or merciful
exactness in a cultural context
that operates at the speed of
the implosion trigger?
It's difficult, certainly.
Right.
We have highly polarized media
institutions that are often
commercially incentivized to
promote outrage, binary moral
judgments.
Is it really realistic to expect
a brittle Republic, as the
source calls it, to suddenly
adopt this complex balancing
act?
You're proposing sort of a
surgical approach in a cultural
environment that seems to demand
broad, immediate, and often
punitive responses.
It may be extraordinarily
difficult, yes, but it remains
the mandatory structural
solution.
According to the source.
The alternative is permanent
instability.
Consider how this works, or
should work, in the legal versus
social spheres.
If a figure says something
deeply racist, the principle of
Stern mercy mandates that the
law, the courts, the state
protects their right to say it
right up until the point of
incitement.
That's the mercy part.
But society, employers,
colleagues, commentators is
obligated to sternly and
fiercely rebuke the content.
That's the sternness.
OK.
The failure occurred, the
argument goes, because
institutions started confusing
the legal sphere with the social
sphere.
They began punishing content as
if it were incitement, thus
concentrating the hostile energy
rather than dispersing it
through robust criticism.
So suppression creates the pit.
Tolerance, when coupled with
strong social rebuke, disperses
the material legally and
addresses the content socially.
But that level of intellectual
precision requires faith in
institutions that the source
material itself suggests have
already failed spectacularly.
The events of that September
week show The detonator was
already set and it was activated
immediately globally,
strategically, the speed and
coordination of the outrage and
political manipulation, the
strategic arrangement of words
using people as quote blasting
caps suggests that the primary
threat is now fundamentally
active and immediate.
If we focus exclusively on
restoring a long term structural
solution like Stern Mercy, we
risk missing the fact that the
digital architecture has made
instantaneous detonation just
too easy.
We might be past the point where
simple structural tolerance is
enough to disperse the energy.
We have to contend with
weaponized amplification that
exploits any pre-existing
weakness immediately.
Well, we certainly agree on the
catastrophic stakes, which the
source confirms by stating quite
starkly that the nuclear analogy
is not hyperbole.
My core warning remains focused
on avoiding the hard dissent.
Suppression is the structural
mechanism that concentrates the
energy, turning a brittle
society into a potential bomb.
Protection of the civic square
coupled with social
accountability is mandatory, I
argue, to prevent that pit from
forming.
And I reiterate that while
suppression is structurally
harmful, absolutely, the
instantaneous and globally
coordinated implosion
demonstrated by the event
surrounding Kirk's death
suggests that the active
strategic amplification and
arrangement of words that high
speed digital architecture
employed by political actors is
the more immediate and potent
threat driving society past
criticality today.
The detonation mechanism itself
is the point of catastrophic
failure, not just the
compression that preceded it.
So we've clearly illuminated 2
profoundly different yet deeply
connected dynamics presented in
the material.
The structural weaknesses caused
it by long term suppression and
the instantaneous targeted
exploitation of those weaknesses
through amplification.
Yes, the tragedy of Charlie
Kirk's death as depicted really
highlights the immense
complexity of balancing speech
protection and social stability,
especially in an age of
instantaneous communication.
Indeed, the material clearly
offers competing explanations
for this collapse, confirming
that the Republic must
immediately address how it
manages speech, recognizing both
the pressure cooker effect of
institutional suppression and
the volatility of high speed
strategic amplification.
Lest his killing truly becomes
The detonator, there is clearly
much more to analyze in the
material regarding this
dangerous dynamic.
Imagine this, a really punishing
hot September afternoon, the sun
just beating down on these huge
empty parking lots outside State
Farm Stadium in Arizona.
But inside, under that giant
roof, the air is just thick, you
know, thick with tension, with
shock, and definitely thick with
political heat. 10s of thousands
of people, not for game, but for
a funeral.
Charlie Kirk's coffin draped in
the flag on this platform.
It felt less like a memorial,
honestly, and more like like war
had just been declared.
And the big screen showing his
face, that familiar grin.
It was just this grim echo of
his usual Turning Point
conferences and the words from
the podium.
Immediate, brutal, completely
unconciliatory, deliberately so.
He had Donald Trump back in the
White House, not really offering
condolences but promising
vengeance.
He said we will not allow
radical left lunatics to destroy
America.
Strong words.
Very strong and right away
setting a tone.
Exactly.
Then JD Vance, the VP, calls
Kirk a martyr to the cause of
truth, amplifying it.
Helping the stakes, framing it
as a martyrdom.
And maybe the most striking
thing, the source notes Cardinal
Dolan comparing Curt to Saint
Paul.
Yeah, which immediately puts the
whole thing into this kind of
cosmic good versus evil battle.
So no room for nuance there.
None.
It wasn't about national
healing.
It was clearly about
accelerating the division.
Yeah.
OK, let's unpack this.
Our mission today really is to
explore this powerful, pretty
unsettling analysis we've been
reading.
It takes this specific event,
Kirk's assassination in 2025,
which was tragic, highly
charged, and uses it like a
forensic tool.
The source material wants to
dissect what happens when a
society tries to suppress
speech, even really unpopular or
frankly ugly speech, instead of
just tolerating.
It What's fascinating here is
how the source frames it.
It calls that single shot in
Utah a Sarajevo moment.
Like Archdude Ferdinand in 1914.
Exactly.
The argument is just like that
one shot tipped a really
brittle, polarize Europe into
war footing.
Kirk's killing acted as a
similar flashpoint.
It instantly turned American
politics into what felt like a
battlefield.
The violence was sudden, yeah,
but the conditions for it, the
essay argues.
They were laid down years
before.
And that brings us to these core
ideas.
We need to explore the latter of
escalation and the big one, the
implosion trigger.
So the essay is basically saying
that when we try to shut down,
talk about a problem, you know,
censor it, punish the speakers,
we essentially turn the
conversation into a bomb.
Is that the gist?
That's precisely the argument,
yeah.
The implosion trigger theory
suggests society is like, well,
like fissile material plutonium,
the essay says.
It doesn't just randomly explode
into political violence.
It gets pushed past a critical
point when dissent, when speech
itself isn't allowed to just air
out, you know, dispulse, when
it's instead concentrated,
compressed, forced into what the
essay calls these darker
channels.
And that's where it
metastasizes.
So we're really diving into the
mechanics of how our speech
environment, according to this
source, created the exact
conditions for this kind of
violence.
And the source claims this
wasn't unforeseeable.
Which is, yeah, a pretty
chilling place to kick things
off.
So let's look closer at that
immediate aftermath, because the
funeral, the reactions right
after, they really show how
brittle things had become.
The sources are clear.
Zero attempt at conciliation.
No reaching across the aisle.
It was a rallying cry, full
stop.
Right, Erica Kirk might have
talked about her husband's voice
living on, but the politicians
on that stage, they grabbed that
platform to sharpen their swords
immediately.
Yeah, prepping for the fight
ahead.
And if you connect that to the
bigger picture, that immediate
fallout just highlights how
completely divided the public
space was.
This inability to find any
common ground, I mean, even a
facing a political murder.
That's the essay's first real
piece of evidence for this
implosion trigger idea.
And there are specific examples,
right?
But yeah, look at the symbolic
stuff the source points out.
Specifically.
Flags flew at half staff in DC
for Kirk.
OK, but they did not fly for
Melissa Hortman, a Democrat
murdered just weeks earlier.
Maybe less politically charged,
sure, but still.
That's wow.
That's a staggering detail.
It's critical, the essay argues,
because it shows the nation
couldn't even mourn together
anymore.
Grief itself was instantly
partisan.
So the official symbols, the
flags.
They validated one side's
victimhood and basically ignored
the others, which just
reinforces this feeling that the
whole system is a battlefield
where only certain lives get
national respect.
And then outside the stadium,
actual physical conflict.
Yeah, protesters clashing with
police, with attendees and
online social media.
They just exploded.
It was an absolute war zone.
Fractured.
Instantly you had hashtags
lamenting genuinely grieving,
and then others just full of
open, vicious Glee.
No middle ground at all.
That vacuum was just filled
instantly with conflict.
And crucially, this wasn't just
happening in the US The source
really stresses the global
convergence.
Swift, immediate.
It mobilized far right movements
everywhere, treating Kirk's
death as this universal
political signal.
You mentioned London.
Yeah, reports of 10s of
thousands marking in London,
holding placards with Kirk's
face, treating him like a global
martyr.
Instantly.
The ideological connection was
just massive and synchronized.
And the ripples in Europe.
You had Matteo Salvini in Rome
saying I cried for Charlie.
Now everything changes.
Right.
The source treats his death not
just as some isolated tragedy,
but as a deliberate political
catalyst.
It proved that this polarization
we talk about, you know, as an
American problem, it has
immediate, volatile
international political weight.
So the murder became
justification.
For global ideological
alignment, yeah.
And promised action.
It showed the implosion wasn't
contained by borders.
Which brings us back to the
essay's point about perception,
doesn't it?
Exactly.
When a big chunk of the
population already sees politics
as a battlefield, like a 0 sum
fight for survival, then a
single dramatic shot like this,
it just instantly confirms that
worst case perception.
So the global reaction, the
funeral, the clashes.
All of it demonstrates this
profound, immediate implosion of
the civic space.
The ground was primed, the essay
argues, by years of suppressed
speech.
The assassination was the spark
that lit the fuse of perceived
war.
And the suggestion is that
people who dismissed Kirk's
rhetoric, you know, they go, oh,
it's just words.
They didn't get the power of
speech to concentrate hostility
when it's pushed underground.
Right.
And that concentration, that's
what we need to get into next,
the actual theory of mechanics
of how this happens.
OK, so now we really need to
dive into the mechanics of this
implosion trigger itself,
because this is where the source
gets, well, really analytical
and maybe disturbing.
It moves beyond just reporting
the event.
It argues this violence was the
inevitable result of a
structural failure, a failure to
manage dissent.
What's fascinating here is the
analogy.
It uses the sophisticated
nuclear physics analogy to
explain how social pressure
turns words into actual kinetic
violence.
Right.
The ladder of escalation that
feels like the starting point,
the path to disaster.
The source details these steps,
how ugly words can turn into a
systemic crisis.
And it starts simply doesn't.
It it does a harsh tweet, an
insult on campus, a provocative
sign at a protest, those are
just the sparks.
The sparks themselves aren't the
issue then.
Not according to this essay, no.
The danger comes from the
institutional response to the
sparks.
Instead of modeling tolerance
even for harsh or unpopular
speech, institutions react
punitively like.
Firing people, Yes.
Expulsions.
Exactly.
Job losses, Expulsions.
Public shaming campaigns, what
gets broadly termed cancel
culture.
The message sent by the cultural
infrastructure is immediate and
overwhelming.
These opinions aren't just
wrong, they are unutterable.
They must be wiped out.
This is where the latter gets
really dangerous.
The source claims the core
mechanism of the trigger is what
happens next.
Right.
The sentiment, the hostility,
the belief behind the speech.
It doesn't just evaporate
because it's banned.
It metastasizes.
That's the word the essay uses.
Metastasizes.
If people can't voice their
hostility openly, the feelings
don't vanish.
They find, quote, darker
channels, and in those channels
they get concentrated,
radicalized, and eventually this
is the critical step.
The suppress group doesn't just
talk privately.
The source warns that a fraction
decides they have to act, not
speak.
That.
Shift from words to action.
That's the penultimate step
before the implosion, the
trigger point.
And this is where the nuclear
analogy comes in to explain that
transition.
Perfectly, according to the
source, it uses the specific
design of an implosion type
nuclear bomb, and it highlights
this stunning irony.
You use conventional explosives
like TNT, meticulously arranged.
To set off something as
terrifying as nuclear fission.
Exactly, and the argument is
suppression is the conventional
explosive charge that triggers
the social fission.
OK, I get the metaphor, but is
it?
I mean, isn't it maybe a bit
much?
Yeah.
Comparing cancel culture to the
lead up to WWII or a nuclear
bomb.
Does the essay address that
potential hyperbole?
It does.
It argues the comparison isn't
about scale, it's about the
mechanism.
The source suggests the
hyperbole is intentional because
it captures that non linear sort
of exponential increase in
danger once you hit criticality.
It says dismissing the link
between suppression and violence
is like saying arranging TNT
around plutonium is fine because
TNT isn't nuclear.
The analogy is about the
structure, the physics of it.
Fair enough.
Let's break down the mechanics
then, piece by piece, like the
essay does.
Socially speaking, we start with
the core, the pit society itself
is this brittle plutonium core.
Polarized?
Yeah, but normally subcritical,
it can't sustain a chain
reaction on its own.
Right.
And to push that core past
criticality, you need these
carefully shaped charges of
conventional explosives around
it, compressing it perfectly
symmetrically.
These are the explosive lenses.
And socially, what are the
lenses?
The essay defines them as the
outrage influencers, the
professional people or maybe
organizations whose main job is
generating and shaping
hostility, directing it at
specific targets.
They don't just report news,
they actively structure the
anger.
So the influencer is the shaped
charge focusing the blast
inward?
Yeah, that makes a terrifying
kind of sense.
Then you need the infrastructure
to deliver the charge, the
detonation wires.
Which in the analogy, are the
retweet storms that rapid,
massive super focus spread of
outrage online, often driven by
algorithms that prioritize speed
above all else.
Why are the wires, the retweets
so crucial?
Because they ensure simultaneous
compression.
If the charge isn't a bonfire
unevenly, the core just kind of
fizzles.
The retweet storm make sure
millions get the same compressed
rage inducing message at almost
the exact same time.
No pause for thought, no counter
argument.
Instant high pressure
uniformity.
That's the social equivalent of
synchronizing the detonation
wires according to this theory.
OK, so influencer shaped the
charge, retweets deliver it
simultaneously.
What provides the actual
compression force?
That's media amplification.
This is where mainstream media,
even when just trying to report
on the conflict, ends up giving
disproportionate attention to
the most extreme voices.
Unintentionally, maybe, but they
end up concentrating the very
hostility they're covering.
Right.
So you put it all together.
Influencers, retweet storms,
media amplification.
They take a society that was
polarized but stable, sub
critical and push it over the
edge.
Hostility becomes reactive.
A runaway reaction starts
political violence.
And the final piece, the
blasting caps, the small things
that set off The Big Bang.
Yeah, these are defined as the
minor incidents that get blown
way out of proportion, like a
comedian's bad joke, a professor
misspeaking in a lecture, some
random ugly tweet from a
teenager.
Small charges.
But precisely placed, the essay
says, to ignite the whole
sequence.
So the implication, the whole
argument, rests on this.
Yeah, the Assassin's bullet,
Tyler Robinson's act.
It wasn't the start of the
explosion.
It was the result, the result of
this implosion sequence set in
motion years earlier by the
systematic decision
institutional cultural, to
suppress and concentrate speech
instead of letting it disperse.
So Kirk's assassination becomes
not just a political murder, but
the inevitable implosion of a
speech environment primed for
exactly that that.
That's the chilling conclusion
the source draws.
OK, so the source then pivots.
It gives us detailed day by day
walkthrough of the week after
the assassination, treating it
as real time proof of the
implosion trigger mechanism in
action, the shooting itself.
Quick, immediate.
Kirk's on stage at Utah Valley
University mid debate.
Tyler Robinson fires from hiding
and the most destabilizing part?
The source really stresses this.
Cameras were rolling.
Raw footage goes global in
minutes.
And that speed is absolutely
key.
It let the compression cycle
start instantly, before any
facts could even be established.
So let's walk through that seven
day timeline.
The source maps out how each day
fed the implosion.
Right Day one, CNN reports the
death, and immediately,
immediately before anyone knows
the shooter's motive, President
Trump provides that rhetorical
charge, blames the radical left.
Yeah, that's the explosive lens
firing instantly, setting the
narrative vengeance, not
investigation.
Exactly, the essay argues it
immediately legitimize that
battlefield perception.
We talked.
About and the lack of hesitation
is key.
No call for calm.
None.
No plea for unity, just
immediate confirmation of the
existing political warfare
narrative.
That White House move just
cranked up the compression
pressure fast.
Day 2, The source notes vigils
popping up not just in Arizona,
but London, Malta.
Which proves that instantaneous
ideological convergence.
Supporters raising crucifixes,
calling Kirk a martyr.
European far right leaders
hailing him, seeing it as
confirmation of this necessary
global fight.
So the compression was global
synchronized, strengthening the
reaction.
Day three, Trump escalates the
formal response.
Using institutional power again
orders flags at half, and the
source cites an ABC News report
plans to posthumously give Kirk
the Presidential Medal of
Freedom.
Which legitimizes the martyrdom
idea even further elevates it
from a crime to this national
historical crisis.
Maximizing the compression.
Maximizing the perceived scale
of the conflict.
OK, day four seems critical.
The cultural backlash, non
political spaces fracturing.
Why focus on figures like
Stephen King or Coldplay?
Because they illustrate that
institutional or cultural
failure to handle the outrage.
When Stephen King tweets
something inflammatory right
away that claim Kirk advocated
stoning gaze, which he later
apologized for, He inadvertently
adds more explosive material,
but the response was just as
destabilizing.
According to the source.
Comedy Central Panics pulls a
South Park episode mocking Kirk.
Why is pulling the episode seen
as a failure?
Because the source sees it as
institutions failing to allow
comic descent or deflation,
eliminating a crucial pressure
release valve.
You remove the possibility of
laughter, diffusing tension in a
crisis, humor, even dark humor
descent.
They can be safety valves
pulling the episode just
reinforce the idea that speech
about Kirk was too explosive,
too dangerous, must be
suppressed, which in the
implosion trigger framework just
increases the density of the
hostility and.
Coldplay.
Their awkward dedication to love
and healing, the source argues.
It just showed mainstream
culture couldn't even
acknowledge the violence without
resorting to these empty,
useless platitudes.
No real engagement.
OK, then come the explicit calls
for vengeance.
The compression is working.
Yep.
Day 5.
Fox News solidifies their side
of the media.
Amplification announces a big
tribute.
Wired.
Reuters report spiking calls for
vengeance online Clear sign the
compressed hostility is finding
an outlet.
And the VP getting involved
directly.
That's maybe the peak of
institutional failure described
here.
The Guardian noted JD Mann's
endorsing A dachshund campaign
against Kirk critics.
The sitting vice president.
Instead of stabilizing,
moderating the anger, the
executive branch actively
participates in the compression,
legitimizing vigilante action.
That's state sanctioned use of
the detonation wires.
Chilling stuff.
The last two days just solidify
the global implosion day 6.
The violence threatens to spill
over.
More armed men show up at an
Arizona memorial.
The threat moves from digital to
physical confrontation.
Trump double s down designates
Antifa a terrorist group, again
amplifying division, not seeking
containment.
Day 7 international frenzy hits
critical mass.
Right.
Elon Musk calls Democrats the
party of murder.
The European Parliament refuses
a moment of silence for Kirk.
Predictably, a French MEP who
supported that gets death
threats.
Showing how the local event
fuels global hostility
instantly.
Exactly.
Even the Pope gets drawn in
praying for Kirk, the source
concludes.
The sequence wasn't random.
It was a textbook, inevitable
implosion of a society
compressed past its breaking
point.
So this next part really tackles
the ethics, the philosophy
behind the analysis, and it
presents this central, really
counterintuitive argument.
It flips how we usually think
about speech right on its head.
The paradox is words have to be
tolerated not because they're
harmless, they're definitely not
harmless, but precisely because
they are dangerous.
That's the absolute core shift
in thinking the source demands.
Yeah, if you connect it back.
The essay argues that
suppressing speech doesn't get
rid of the danger, it just
concentrates the ideology,
creates a higher density of
hostility, pushes that social
pit closer to criticality.
So trying to enforce civility
through censorship or
punishment.
Only ensures the underlying
venom finds a more destructive
outlet than just words.
Words, paradoxically, are the
container for the venom.
Let them out, the argument goes.
So if a university fires a
professor for, I don't know,
terrible offensive joke, the
essay says that action actually
makes society less safe.
Significantly less safe is the
argument, because the
institution just modeled that
the only acceptable response to
offensive speech is immediate
career ending exclusion.
And this leads to a really harsh
critique of the institutions
themselves.
Employers, universities, media,
the ones that should be the
cooling rods in society.
The source suggests that when
they cancel speakers, fire staff
for jokes, expel students, they
aren't preventing explosions.
They're actively arranging the
lenses the phrase used,
preparing the pit for
detonation.
They send the message that
certain idea can't be debated or
refuted, they can only be
annihilated.
Yeah, a devastating critique of
institutional function.
They're not absorbing dissent.
They're amplifying outrage.
Treating every ideological slip
up as a capital offense needing
total exclusion.
And this brings us to that
historical analogy, the mini
Versailles.
Right, the Versailles analogy
that feels like one of the most
intellectually potent and maybe
disturbing parallels in the
whole piece remind us why
Versailles applies to cancel
culture.
OK, so the Treaty of Versailles
ended World War One famously
punitive towards Germany,
crushing reparations, loss of
territory.
The key historical lesson,
widely accepted, is that this
punishment was so severe, so
humiliating, so absolute, it
directly bred the resentment and
instability that allowed Hitler
and the Nazis to rise, leading
to World War Two.
OK, the essay argues, every time
a powerful institution punishes
or cancels one side ruthlessly,
without nuance or mercy, they're
not winning a culture war,
they're performing a mini
Versailles.
They're breeding the resentment,
the silence, the desire for
vengeance that will inevitably
fuel the next, potentially much
more violent conflict.
Suppression creates the
conditions for violent payback.
So institutional failure, this
lack of resilience, this embrace
of punitive cancellation, that's
the core mechanisms beating up
the implosion.
And this failure, the source
says, creates the need for a
different framework, something
it calls stern mercy, something
secular institutions seem unable
to provide.
Exactly.
The argument is that modern
culture doesn't get either side
of the equation right.
We either indulge everything,
total permissiveness, nothing
matters, or we punish
mercilessly, Total vengeance.
Everything's a capital crime.
And both extremes are
destabilizing.
Profoundly, because they strip
speech of both responsibility
and freedom.
So to find that balance, the
source looks to theology, citing
John's Gospel.
Yeah, where Christ tells the
woman caught in adultery,
neither do I condemn you.
Go and sin no more.
That's presented as the perfect
example of the paradoxical
balance we've lost.
What is that balance exactly?
It means the community or
society has to forgive the
Sinner or in this context,
protect the speaker and their
right to speak no matter how
offensive the words might be,
while at the same time naming
and rebuking the sin or the
ugliest parts of the speech
contest.
Protect the person, protect the
right, but refute the bad idea
mercilessly.
That's the necessary
combination, the essay argues.
Sternness and reputation and
mercy in protection.
That's what holds freedom and
responsibility together,
stabilizes the public square,
and without it, you get that
oscillation between total
permissiveness and total
vengeance, which leads to
violence, the collapse of the
public sphere into, quote,
laughter and bullets.
Wow, that's a powerful thought.
The square held together by
holding those two contradictory
ideas.
So what does Stern mercy look
like?
Practically?
The essay gives 4 steps to
stabilize this civic square.
Right.
Yeah, 4 concrete requirements.
First is legal restraint,
absolute adherence to the
Brandenburg Doctrine.
Mind us, speech is only
punishable if it incites
imminent lawless action.
That bar has to stay high.
If we lower it, say to punish
words that just hurt feelings or
cause discomfort, we start
punishing expressions.
Expression itself, which is what
concentrates hostility and
primes the pit.
The legal system must tolerate
ugly noise, OK?
2nd.
Institutional resilience.
This is the tough one for big
organizations, universities,
companies, media.
They have to fight that
immediate algorithmic urge to
punish every single
transgression.
They need to tolerate dissent,
even hateful speech that doesn't
meet the Brandenburg test model
of thicker skin for everyone
else.
So if someone says something
stupid but not actually inciting
violence.
The response should be debate
refutation, not firing them
instantly. 3rd is cultural
toughness.
This sounds like it's on us, the
individuals.
It is the burden is on the
citizen.
We have to individually learn to
hear ugly words, hurtful words,
false words without collapsing
culturally.
We have to stop equating words
with physical violence because
the source notes collapsing that
distinction.
Saying speech is violence is
exactly what ends up justifying
real violence against speech.
Violence is violence.
Speech is speech.
Keep them separate.
Vitally important for stability,
the essay argues.
But how realistic is that in
this age of constant algorithmic
outrage?
The source acknowledges it's
hard, but it argues the outrage
algorithms only exploit A
weakness that's already there,
our cultural drift towards
fragility.
Cultural toughness isn't a
luxury, it's presented as a
necessity.
If we demand institutions
protect us from uncomfortable
ideas, we're basically asking
them to compress society for us.
OK, and the last one, merciful
exactness.
This basically sums up the Stern
mercy idea.
Rigorously defend the speaker's
right to speak, but also
mercilessly refute the content
if it's genuinely ugly or wrong.
So protect the square, but fight
the bad ideas within it.
Exactly, the essay warns the
alternative to this careful
balance.
The alternative is just torches.
You either engage the ugly idea
or you eliminate the person
speaking it.
And the lesson from Kirk's
death?
Is that a society?
Choosing elimination over
engagement is choosing
implosion.
So wrapping this up, the core
warning seems to be about that
ladder of escalation climbing
from ugly words to political
violence.
It's terrifyingly easy to go up,
but.
Profoundly hard to come back
down.
Outrageous.
Effortless, isn't it?
Restraint is exhausting.
We saw that in the immediate
global reaction to Kirk's death.
Absolutely.
Sarajevo proved it a century
ago.
Versailles proved that
punishment just sews the seeds
for the next worst war.
And the essay leaves us with
that final, stark image.
The nuclear analogy isn't just
hyperbole.
No society is the plutonium pit,
always near critical mass,
always brittle because of our
differences and words.
All words, good, bad, true,
false interestness.
They are the charges placed
around it.
We can't eliminate the charges.
People will always say ugly
things, false things.
That's not the choice.
The choice then, is just about
how we arrange them.
Do we suppress them?
Concentrate them?
Use outrage, influencers,
cancellations, media
amplification to arrange them
perfectly.
Pushing us past criticality
until we implode?
Or do we choose the much harder
path?
Do we tolerate them?
Allow counter speech, rigorous
debate to disperse them
harmlessly into the air?
And sure, they never reached
that critical density.
The death of Charlie Kirk was
obviously a deep personal
tragedy, but the essays ultimate
warning is that this tragedy
gets infinitely worse if his
killing becomes The detonator
for a Republic, for a civic
square that can't tell the
difference anymore between
speech and war.
Yeah.
And maybe the final thought for
you listening is whether you as
an individual choose to
participate in that compression
or whether you choose the
harder, slower path, that path
of stern mercy, of cultural
toughness needed to disperse the
hostility.
Because the ultimate tragedy
would be learning the cost of
implosion only afterwards, too
late.
Welcome.
Today we're looking at a piece
that uses a fictional Charlie
Kirk assassination to explore
how suppressing speech cancel
culture can trigger implosion
and lead to violence.
It's a powerful concept.
Let's get straight into the
feedback.
OK, first up the ladder of
escalation.
I really like the nuclear
analogy here, the idea that
suppression concentrates
descent.
Me too.
It's a strong image, but this is
also maybe the first area where
we could strengthen the
structure a bit.
While the essay establishes a
powerful theoretical correlation
between the punitive suppression
of ugly words and subsequent
kinetic violence, the conceptual
link between social ostracism
and physical action needs to be
structurally fortified.
Yeah, I felt that too.
It moves quite quickly from, you
know, institutional punishments
like job loss or public shaming.
Right expulsions.
Straight to the kinetic outcome.
That line, some fraction of
those silenced will act, not
speak.
It's compelling, but.
It leans heavily on the physics
metaphor, doesn't it?
It is nuclear physics, but the
the human pathway isn't fully
mapped out.
Exactly.
That's the weakness.
The psychological or
sociological bridge between
feeling that social pain and
actually resorting to violence
feels a bit abstract.
We see the fuel being
concentrated, but not quite the
engine turning it into force.
So the suggestion is to dedicate
a bit more space to analyzing
that process.
How does radicalization actually
happen in those darker channels?
Define what form this
metastasization takes when
sentiments cannot be spoken, and
detail the steps between feeling
unutterable and choosing
violence.
We need to show that internal
shift.
OK, how do we do that concretely
without, you know, bogging it
down?
Well, one way is to lean into
the sociology.
How does resentment harden went
to a political grievance?
The essay already mentions JD
Vance's point about becoming a
martyr to the cause of truth.
Right.
Losing your job for a joke turns
you into a sacrifice.
Exactly.
That shift itself is the
mechanism.
So one approach is detailing how
the loss of a job for a joke
escalates to viewing oneself as
a martyr, providing that moral
justification for, well, extreme
actions.
That makes the connection much
clearer.
It traces the psychological
path.
And then there's the
environment, those darker
channels.
We need to specify them.
I think so.
Another approach is to
explicitly analyze what those
darker channels are.
Maybe specific digital echo
chambers show how that shared
exclusion amplifies the
subcritical insult into critical
mass.
So it goes from I was punished
to we were punished and then.
The system needs to be dealt
with something like that.
Defining the psychology and the
location makes the whole
implosion trigger concept feel
much more grounded, more
intellectually solid.
Got it.
OK, let's move on to the
assassination itself, the
fictional case study.
Which is incredibly vivid,
really grabs you.
The chronology is powerful.
It definitely is, but I suspect
you're going to say its main
function right now is more
narrative than analytical.
Slightly yes.
The fictional case study of
Charlie Kirk's assassination is
incredibly vivid and engaging,
but the highly detailed
chronology currently functions
more as a narrative timeline
than a direct illustration of
the core implosion trigger
mechanism.
Right.
That section, a week in
September, lists all the
reactions.
Trump's blame.
Coldplay's song.
The Pope.
It shows the outcome of the
implosion, but doesn't
explicitly demonstrate how the
explosive lenses, as the essay
calls them, or working in real
time during that week.
So the weakness is that the
theoretical concepts like
outrage influencers are
introduced earlier.
But then the timeline just lists
events sequentially.
Stephen King's tweet, Comedy
Central pulling South Park
Musk's comments.
They're mentioned, but not
directly tagged within that
timeline as functional parts of
the trigger mechanism.
OK, so the suggestion here is
about integration.
Precisely, stop using the case
study just as a backdrop and
start using it as active
evidence for the theory.
Integrate the specific examples
from the day one to seven
timeline directly into the
theoretical sections that define
the implosion trigger.
Yes, the strength of the
fictional event should be used
to provide direct specific
labels for the actors and
events, making the theory highly
concrete.
So the theory names the
character, and the character's
action proves the theory.
Exactly when the essay talks
about outrage, influencers or
explosive lentes.
Perfect.
Or it should immediately say,
like Trump blaming the left on
day one, Perfect.
Or identify Elon Musk calling
Democrats the party of murder on
Day 7 as a specific example of
outrage amplification.
That makes the connection
explicit.
It really leverages the
fictional element.
It turns the story into part of
the analytical engine, and you
can do the same with
institutional responses, right?
Like the South Park episode
being pulled.
Absolutely frame that not just
as, you know, institutional
fear, but as an active part of
the mechanism, an amplifier of
outrage rather than a moderator.
Because it reinforces the
punishment aspect from the
latter of escalation.
Exactly.
Show how that specific fictional
institutional failure proves the
danger of overcorrection.
It makes the whole argument feel
tighter, more interwoven.
Theory and narrative working
together, not just side by side.
OK, that makes sense.
Now for the third main point,
the solution.
Stern mercy.
Which is a brilliant concept,
really cuts through that binary
of indulge endlessly or punished
mercilessly.
It's the philosophical anchor
drawing on that gospel phrase.
Neither do I condemn you.
Go and sin no more.
Very profound.
But.
But the concept of stern mercy
to protect the speaker while
rebuking the speech is the
philosophical anchor of the
solution.
Yet the transition from this
theological paradox to the
practical solutions is
significantly underdeveloped.
Yeah, the essay sets up this
powerful dichotomy.
And then offer solutions like
legal restraint, institutional
resilience, cultural toughness.
But it doesn't fully spell out
how a modern institution, or
even just a person, actually
does that delicate balance act,
that merciful exactness.
That's the weakness.
There's a gap between the high
level ethic and the actionable
steps.
How do you turn this quite
complex theological idea into,
say, HR policy?
Or a university's code of
conduct.
Without it just becoming
permission or punishment again.
Exactly.
And bridging that gap is the
opportunity.
Here we must define a clear,
practical framework for how
institutions, universities,
corporations can incorporate
sternness and mercy
simultaneously, ensuring the
proposed solution avoids
collapsing into either simple
permissiveness or vengeance.
Actual mechanism.
How do you enforce
responsibility without, you
know, destroy someone?
Right, so let's think about
concrete examples, specific
policies.
Take a corporation.
An employee makes a
controversial comment online,
maybe on their private social
media.
The usual paths are ignore it or
fire them, indulgence or
vengeance.
So, stern mercy for a
corporation instead of immediate
firing, vengeance punishment for
controversial comment, the
company could defend the right
to speak mercy by retaining
employment while mandating that
the employee publicly
participate in a constructive
debate or educational module
designed to analyze the impact
of the content.
Sternness.
OK, I like that Mercy is keeping
the job.
Sternness is requiring
engagement with the consequences
of the speech.
It models resilience.
It demands responsibility
without resorting to just
punitive action.
And for a university, maybe with
a controversial speaker.
Same principle, instead of
justice canceling them under
pressure, the university could
defend the speakers right to be
there Mercy, but simultaneously
fund and promote strong
counterprogramming that
rigorously critiques or refutes
the speaker's ideas sternness.
Defend the square, but rebuke
the sin intellectually.
Precisely, it strengthens that
cultural toughness idea by
replacing censorship with robust
debate.
It shows that stern mercy isn't
just about being nice.
It's a policy.
It demands something merciful.
Exactness.
Exactly.
It makes the solution feel
achievable, not just
aspirational.
OK, this all feels very
actionable.
The core thesis is strong, but
these refinements could really
elevate it.
Agreed.
So just to quickly recap the
main opportunities we discussed.
First, really nail down that
link between social ostracism
and actual violence.
Define the psychological pathway
more explicitly.
Show the radicalization process.
2nd.
Weave that excellent Charlie
Kirk case study directly into
the theoretical framework.
Use the fictional events and
people as the examples of the
implosion trigger components.
Make the narrative serve the
analysis directly and 3rd
operationalize stern mercy.
Right.
Provide concrete policy examples
for institutions, corporations,
universities, showing how they
can implement both the mercy and
the sternness together.
Avoid the trap of just being
permissive or or just being
punitive.
By integrating these
suggestions, the essay can move
from being a really compelling
speculative piece to a robust
and truly actionable
philosophical argument.
We definitely encourage you to
explore these revisions.
We think they'll significantly
enhance the impact of the work.
And please submit the updated
version back to us for another
look.